Kim is so relatable I've always have
been insecure about my trapezius muscle
and you know if she wants to not have
one in her photos why
why does she need one Spencer Pratt
trolling Kim Kardashian for a Photoshop
fail breaking news the reality stars
calling out this snap of the beauty
Mogul from earlier this month in the
pool sipping a drink Kim even shared a
video of the poolside moment
[Music]
and that quickly caught the attention of
a tick-tocker who pointed out a
difference in Kim's neckline between the
photo and the video Kim K is notorious
for photoshopping out her tracks why I
don't know maybe it makes her neck look
smaller but this area right here has
been photoshopped out when we zoom in we
can see that the water pattern behind
her here has been warped yep and that
vid then caught the eye of Spencer who
couldn't help but poke fun
Kim is so relatable I've always been
insecure about my trapezius muscle and
you know if she wants to not have one in
her photos why
why does she need one and I I stand by
this because I mean look at that who
needs that muscle supporting your neck
it's just I guess it's a stupid muscle
well when Spencer's not busy trolling
Kim he's preparing to become a father of
two only E.T was with him and his wife
Heidi for their gender reveal three two
one
congratulations
yep it's two boys for the Pratt
household do you feel ready to be a dad
of two
oh this is announcing what the gender
was so real
um no I am not I I'm not ready because I
still don't actually feel ready as
currently as a father every day
a new day of a journey and yeah I don't
think you can get ready you can pretend
but like oh here's another life you're
responsible for
do you guys dream of a big family or at
this point now are you thinking like
we're gonna be four and that's good and
we're good
how are you looking at me I'd like to
hear your answer that's what this is
about
um
who knows what life has around the
corner
um you know
really thought past this uh this current
situation with that coming but yeah I
think if God wants to bless us with
another miracle because that sure wasn't
easy I definitely not worried about
getting pregnant for a third time
[Music]